I am asking again for all the prayers
mega prayers right now Nick Cordero is
in need of a miracle his wife Amanda
cludes took to her Instagram story to
give fans an update on the Broadway
stars health and according to her it's
going downhill nick has had a bad
morning unfortunately things are going a
little downhill at the moment so I am
asking again for all the prayers mega
prayers right now please cheer and
please pray for Nick today and I know I
know that this virus is not gonna get
him down before Amanda ended the video
she made this declaration it's not how
historians so just keep us in your
thoughts and prayers today thank you
Amanda's update comes a week after she
announced Nick had woken up from his
coma following his battle with the
coronavirus Nick
Dadda is a wake yeah just as recently as
Monday
Amanda shared that she got a little bit
of good news from Nick's doctor and made
plans to celebrate quote the small wind
throughout Nick's health battle the
couple and their adorable son Elvis have
been receiving constant support from
family friends and fans please cheer and
please pray for Nick today after Amanda
gave that update her followers took to
social media to hashtag dance for Nick
[Applause]
she reposted these heartwarming videos
along with this message from jennifer
Love Hewitt
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]